hello and welcome to Beth Rigby
interviews now my studio is a little bit
different today because I'm in a much
more exciting theater than Westminster
in some ways because I'm here at Villa
Park home of Aston Villa to talk about
the future of football and English
football hasn't it had a few very
turbulent years
the controversial and short-lived
Breakaway European Super League cause
ruptures in the game and exposed a
disconnect between top clubs and fans
owners took the blame but is the idea of
a breakaway League really dead or could
the Premier League's Global Investors
have bigger plans in the future Aston
Villa's chief executive Christian Paso
has had a long career in football having
previous worked at Liverpool and Chelsea
he was vehemently against the super
league and has big thoughts on Club
ownership we sat down to discuss all of
that and much more
[Music]
all right Christian we're at Villa Park
I've never been here before and my eye
has been drawn to this giant
trophy yeah well rightly so that is the
the cabinet yeah that's the European Cup
its original name the tournament as you
know is now called the champions league
but we're one of five English clubs to
have won it
1982 one nil against Bayern Munich uh
the proudest moment in our club's
history
I actually do yeah could you tell
yeah okay excuse me have you cleaned
Beth's Rigby seats oh yeah she wants to
be Mr Emirates here oh Mr Emery here we
go there you go you sit there I'll be
your I'll be the opposing manager
I wouldn't if I was a manager though I
wouldn't be sitting here would I be out
there
why don't you have a little bit of so
this is so the manager sits here all the
subs are here subson coaches lots of
coaches have a little and then and then
when they're playing they come out here
and go nuts
well something more expressive than
others but does Mr Emery go nuts was he
a bit calmer he's pretty expressive do
you ever go nuts what in my seat yeah I
do so not one final question mainly when
we score when you're when you're when
you're the CEO and um you know you're
passionate about the club but also
there's a financial incentive right to
get into European football
um is it really unpleasant watching a
match
well that's a really interesting word it
is definitely
not pleasure
um until and unless the game is won it's
so lovely when on occasions your team
has
let's say you're three nil up with 10
minutes to go that is a different
watching experience to most of the time
as a premier league exec where the
outcome is in the is up in the air and
it is more stressful than pleasurable
and given that um you are close
it's a European qualification yeah do
you think that the remaining how many
games have you got six or seven games of
the seat do you think it's going to take
a few years off your life
into this season worrying about it I
don't think so I don't think so so
you're in a nice place for the much
nicer Place well look thank you for
showing me your absolutely stunning
ground it's beautiful
now you're a football businessman
and you run Aston Villa but it's all
football fans know it's about passion
football isn't it not the bottom line so
the first question I had for you is who
did you support as a child
which football team I supported
Liverpool I had um I was a third
generation my grandparents and my father
were from Liverpool and Liverpool fans
and so like many many football fans in
the country one grows up as a kid
following in your dad's footsteps so you
you back Liverpool as a kid and then
when you are running Aston Villa
um you had Stephen Gerrard here didn't
you as the Manager of Liverpool Legend
now
running a club's also about tough
decisions isn't it and and you had to
sack Stephen as manager
um a club that you support and that you
used to run supported was that a type
was that very tough for you
yes it was it was very tough he's a very
good he's a very good person I've known
him a long time when I when I was at
Liverpool he was the captain of the club
but my priority is Aston Villa and doing
the right thing for our club and it
hadn't worked out for Stephen he'd be
the first to admit that and we have to
do the right thing and
the board thought about things I think I
think we let things ride for a while and
then made that tough decision and moved
on and you've moved on actually with
great success haven't you because you
got the former Arsenal manager Emery to
join it's been a huge succession you'll
give me a little smile there because I
bet you didn't really expect that to
happen but a few months ago right well
it's fair to say the Improvement has
been really dramatic pronounced and and
and faster than anyone would reasonably
expect we knew what we were getting in
terms of his track record and profile
but the speed with which he's improved
people individually has been pleasantly
surprising you've also got plans to
expand the stadium as part of the UK and
Irish 2028 bid for the Euros how big are
the Ambitions for Villa Park we need to
modernize and bring the stadium into the
21st century we also have would you
believe 33 000 people on a waiting list
who can't watch their beloved Villa so
it's incumbent on us to grow Row the
capacity of the stadium the stand you're
sitting in this North Stand will come
down it currently has about 6 000 seats
post rebuild a completely new North
Stand will get the capacity up to 50 000
and as you mentioned that's really
important because to host uh
International tournaments UA for
tournaments or FIFA tournaments the
specifications are very demanding and
one of them is to have 50 000 seats for
for late round games so bringing Villa
Park compliant with those regs means we
can host a game in the euros and that's
our Dream after the problems of Euro
2020 you concerned that UEFA will be
that think twice before looking at
England now given what happened which
was horrific yeah it was horrific I was
at the game yeah my son was there as
well and it was awful yeah well to
answer your question directly yes I
guess they will look at it but there are
many positives that hopefully outweigh
those issues and as we all do in being
football administrators sometimes it
takes a crisis or a particularly bad
moment to address to identify and
address a problem properly let's look at
another terrible day at the office for
some of the um Premier League football
clubs I want to just ask you about the
legacy of the Super League remember six
of the biggest football clubs signing up
to a plan for a breakaway League that
could have killed off the sport as we
know it what was your reaction as CEO of
Aston Villa when you heard about those
plans
well I was quoted on the morning after
saying they were grotesque and I I spoke
as a football fan as well as a football
administrator
it is deeply regrettable that any people
involved in those clubs and it's been
unclear ever since whether it was some
or all of the six clubs but certainly it
was an example of where
um clubs can clubs owners can get
disconnected from from what their fans
and even what their players and managers
might think and for anyone at those
clubs to think that their fans would
like to be shoehorned into a European
tournament not on Merit but on some
other basis no real football fan would
tolerate that and I must say Beth and
this is important in terms of talking
about regulation for me it was amazingly
heartening that the entire football
family
fans
clubs players managers even the players
and managers of some of those clubs
involved
coalesced in less than 36 hours to
destroy that concept and so although
you're right it played its part in
triggering the so-called fan-led review
in my opinion that problem was dealt
with amazingly efficiently and I must
give credit to government as well I
remember when the government said the
next morning we're going to drop a
legislative time bomb on these matches
we knew that moment that the concept was
dead Christian you're a businessman as
well right just if you've been back at
Liverpool or Chelsea are you really
telling me that seeing the financial
prize that other clubs were signing up
to you wouldn't have gone into the Super
League
if you'd had the opportunity yeah I'm
saying that you really wouldn't have
well in my job let's remember I'm you
know I'm the chief executive of the club
my job is to be the eyes and ears of
ownership on the ground and I would have
told my owners that our fans will not
approve of a concept that goes against
the very essence of English football for
the last 150 years do you think now that
the European Super League is dead or is
it resting
I think it's dead and that is because
again in the wake of it and I mentioned
this when we were talking earlier about
about a different example of a crisis in
football crises tend to Galvanize
administrators and the reaction to the
Super League in all levels of football
was profound within the Premier League
bet we initiated rules black and white
rules and owners Charter that makes
quite explicit if any executive of any
club tries to enter an unregulated
tournament going forward that club will
suffer huge points deduction Chris I
want to ask you about ownership football
ownership you know you're one of the few
people that have really experienced this
executive level running some of the
biggest clubs in the country fast at
Liverpool and then from Liverpool you
then you went to work for Chelsea with
Roman Abramovich and he's a view like
the sort of original Sports washroom
that he used his status as owner of a
premium league club to normalize
relations with Russian oligarchs with
links to Putin of course hindsight's a
wonderful thing isn't it and at the time
there wasn't issues around Abramovich
but subsequently we've seen what's
happened with the war and and what's
happened to him at the time do you
remember did you have qualms for going
to work for him back then or was it just
a very different world yeah I did I most
definitely did
um I don't regret it in the sense that
you know I had a very
that club had reached a point and I
think it was about 11 years into Roman
abramovich's tenure at the club
very very significant period in the
history of English football because as
you say it really was the first takeover
of its type it's now become much more
topical but for much of that period
before Financial regulation came into
play really Mr Abramovich was financing
the transformation of that football
club's fortunes on and off the field
with his own money
and he had plenty of money and so it had
a dramatic impact on improving Chelsea's
fortunes
by the time I arrived round about the
time I arrived in a Strictly Business
role the rules were biting the rules
that basically sit here today not off
not understood by everybody but that
fundamentally in fact are designed to
prevent people like Abramovich
impossibly wealthy people buying
football clubs and transforming them
transforming their fortunes with
unlimited deployment of their wealth in
retrospect do you think British football
should have rolled out the red carpet
for Abramovich
that's a really good question I think I
think
you know the same as being said today
about Abu Dhabi and Manchester City and
about Saudi Arabia and Newcastle
um
yeah I don't I don't I haven't thought
of it in those terms there's certainly
there's so let's put it this way let's
put it this way you wouldn't find a
single Chelsea fan who regrets uh what
Abramovich bought to that football club
I mean it really well in under his
ownership the club experienced
absolutely staggering on-field success
and most fans care most about that and
the kind of moral dimension of Club
ownership
um did what happened with Abramovich
um
change your view because I think after
the Salisbury poisonings you did call
for the boycott of the World Cup in
Russia didn't you yes I did I did so you
do think there's a moral Dimension to
football or football ownership
well I think in that particular instance
I think you know you use the phrase
earlier Sports washing
um in the wake of that particular
appalling incident in the UK in the
run-up to that tournament yeah I was
very clear in my mind that great
football Nations going along with that
tournament England France Spain Germany
had had the capacity if they chose to
deploy it to really shine a light on
what was going on and um yeah I'm proud
of that and Kristen what do you think
about if I put human rights back in mind
what do you have what is your view of
the Saudi Sovereign wealth fund taking
over
Newcastle
well that ship has sailed and
um I think again I mentioned earlier
that
speaking in a you know speaking as a
football administrator there is nothing
in the football rule book that could or
would have prevented that takeover many
people
think there should be and could be but I
think that's pretty unrealistic
um you know if you think about if you
think about the idea of this country's
relationship with friendly states with
allies Nations on which we rely I was
looking I was looking Only Yesterday
people are talking a lot about the
potential takeover of Manchester United
and and the potential for Qatar to buy
to be involved in that you know this is
a country on whom we depend for our
energy supplies in the last 12 months so
it seems to me wholly unrealistic to
imagine a group of football Executives
whether the Premier League board or
other clubs to block takeovers of
football clubs when those nations are
freely able to trade with our country
more broadly where I see my role and
this is my really important point of
view on this Beth is we have to make
sure
going that we do not encourage a
situation where our national sport is
radically transformed in terms of its
balance the competition you talked about
by having Nations control clubs and
deploying on unlimited wealth on the
field but are you concerned that there
is an unlimited amount of pot of money
that can now go into Newcastle I am I am
and I think that's a more legitimate
concern for a football executive than
essentially asking a small group a very
narrow constituency of football
administrators to effectively apply a
form of sanctioning to individuals or
regimes that no national government has
sanctioned yeah let me put it another
way then I I understand that do you
think there should be tighter regulation
on ownership then it takes it out of
your hand as a you don't you don't
you're not you execute a decision made
by a government rather than or a
regulator rather than taking the
decision yourself well you will you will
not be surprised to know and it's an
extremely an extremely opposite and
timely question because the so-called
owners and directors test which is the
soul means by which football the Premier
League or the efl depending on which
League the club plays in that is the
only basis upon which the Premier League
or efl rule on a takeover those rules
are extremely narrowly defined
historically basically criminals or
people who have been involved in
bankruptcies can be barred from taking
over clubs those rules are being
tightened but to be clear they are being
tightened with a language that is
completely consistent with with law and
with you know in individuals that are
sanctioned in law cannot be allowed to
buy football clubs what we're not doing
is having a separate set of football
rules that somehow Trump or override
decisions taken by governments on our
behalf I think that's realistic so you
think that that's what the alternative
seems to me to be crazy in terms of
Saudi the Saudi issue there are some
there is a question about whether or not
the Crown Prince is involved
in the actual
fund behind Newcastle it was meant to be
separate from yes The Sovereign
Nation there's a case in America in
which the Saudis are arguing the
opposite and that they're saying that um
that it is a sovereign wealth fund
um well I think it's true but do you
think the Premier League basically need
to investigate it who really is claiming
ownership and the links of the Crown
Prince to the yes I do and I think they
are and they would if there is a
contradiction in representations made at
the time of the Takeover as to the
nature of the relationship between the
rulers of that country The Sovereign
wealth fund and Newcastle of course the
Premier League I'm sure are
investigating that because they won't
say publicly if they are or not but you
think they are I'd be certain they are
but my point Beth is and I don't think
this is as well understood is that even
if the Crown Prince himself had stood up
on television and said I am proud that
our Sovereign wealth fund is buying
Newcastle and I'm looking forward to be
personally involved because I love
football I love the idea of the Saudi
Arabian Nation being indirectly involved
in English football and I look forward
to my first game at St James's park
there is nothing in the rule book that
would have prevented that happening and
I don't think people understand that now
if we were talking about you know
for example you know the leader of North
Korea which is a which sits on a
sanctioned list then there would be
rules to prevent it but this is what
people don't understand football is not
going to take a line on those
individuals that's at odds with that
taken by our elected government to Man
City then first Club to take serious
money from an All-State the UAE uh
which has a way for human records rights
but record but that's another problem
Pockets so deep that they've spent
billions on a club that now dominate
English football as a consequence
um you know they've got two fast team
squads they're probably going to win the
league they win the Ling all the time
um
isn't the risk that the premier league
has become and simply a battle between
those who are willing to spend the most
on players rather than what it's
designed for which is the sort of a
meritocracy and a fight
between clubs are you worried about that
it just seems that it's so I am with all
these profoundly worried about it then I
wish I had put it as well as you just
did
um
it is it is a clear and present danger
I'll speak as a football fan I don't
want to look back in 20 years time and
say that I was part of a group that are
asleep at the wheel
and in 20 years time we look back and
three teams controlled by nations are
the only three teams winning the Premier
League ever again how do we stop that we
stop it with what we have today which is
extremely strict Financial rules it's
such a fallen file a financial fair play
rules are under investigation and the
truth is isn't it that nobody thinks
anything can be done about it
um
you don't I don't agree with that I do
agree that there is a widely held
opinion and I share it that for many
years Financial regulation has been two
Lacks to
um too ambiguous to complex
therefore too difficult to enforce
combined with an unwillingness to
enforce so I think that's changing and
you mentioned this earlier in the wake
of the Super League there have been wide
ranging changes in the way football is
run the Premier League again I haven't
read this anywhere Beth but I really
enjoy telling you this the Premier
League now has for the first time four
independent professional non-executive
directors running the board and it's no
coincidence in the last six eight weeks
two clubs have been prosecuted for
financial rules where nobody had been
prosecuted for years so so I think it's
changing so you think I wanted to change
what about what about the other thing
that in terms of money which is the
transfer Levy
um the idea of a transfer levy on
international players coming in or
transfers between Premier League players
what do you think of that proposal well
this is just a different way
to transfer money within the ecosystem
of English football I think it's a
really good idea I mean think of more
your world than my world but you know
when we brought in what seemed at the
time to be very high rates of stamp Duty
on the property Market they took the
heat out of the very top end of the
property market so I think it would be a
very good methodology it's not in the
white paper no but that's
that's another issue you know I don't
believe
that it makes any sense whatsoever for a
regulator an appointed
um a politically appointed regulator to
be delving into the way in which we
distribute monies within English
football leave that to the football
authorities we currently distribute it
by a simple transfer of Revenue so right
now over 500 million pounds goes from
the Premier League into the lower
pyramid literally four and a half
million pounds to every Championship
Club it's called solidarity I think the
issue here Christian is that talking
about a new regulatory government
regulator that you you know you're
saying that's already heavily regulated
isn't it you've actually said that too
powerful regulates also risk killing the
Golden Goose yeah but isn't the problem
that the golden eggs aren't being shared
out fairly well I think I think two
things firstly um
we are already in negotiations to
increase those handouts okay let's be
clear that's what they are they are
simple transfers of wealth from the top
of the league down the pyramid and it's
the right thing to do and it's the right
thing to do because it hasn't been
modernized for far too long Beth teams
come out you understand that we're
co-dependent on we're co-dependent on
each other teams come out of the
championship into the Premier League and
they're bridging a huge gap in terms of
their TV income and what the New Deal is
trying to do is to help reduce that
Cliff Edge effect when teams go up and
down promoted and relegated
I don't need a government official to
tell us how to do that or to do that
we're doing it anyway yeah but you know
you know the dangerous smaller clubs you
know risk going bankrupt as well I mean
it seems to me that you seem okay with
the regulator to be involved in
financial sustainability but you don't
want it to go much further it's sort of
almost like a bit of a toothless
regulator you don't seem to want any
more redistribution of money from Rich
to poorer clubs or you said you don't
want to regulate it to meddle in
sporting sanctions in a way it's to I
don't I really don't but we it seems
like we're having a debate and concern
about the way in English football's
going in the way in which kind of super
wealths embedded in the league but then
you're also saying to me you think it
should be business as usual no I'm not
saying it should be business as usual
I'm saying that there has been a very
significant change in the governance of
football in the last two years
strengthening of rules concrete
regulations to prevent some of the very
thing you know the berry takeover is
always cited as a catalyst for a
regulator there were flaws in that efl
rule book that enabled a takeover that
was ultimately destructive to happen
those rules have been shut we talked
about the ESL Beth being essentially
destroyed in 36 hours and new rules that
apply a 30-point deduction for any club
looking at joining a Super League again
so we're taking isolated moments really
bad moments in English football they've
been dealt with and then that being a
case for an ongoing and permanent
regulator I like the idea that the
government wants to be involved in our
national sport these are hugely
important institutions in their
communities economically and socially so
it's right they're interested but yes
I'm listening to government and light
touch intervening in real crises
focusing on the need and not creating
problems or providing solutions to
problems that have already been fixed so
the only thing you actually really want
is limits on how much
incredibly deep pocketed owners can
spend in the transfer market is that
basically what you want
no I'm saying that if you mean from a
regulator I think it's more likely that
a regulator Beth will have a more
valuable role to play in the lower
levels of football where where let's
face it money is tighter the pool of
people wanting to take over football
clubs is much narrower the quality and
experience of management willing to go
into those businesses is less
experienced that's where I think
government have a legitimate role to
play in focusing on the sustainability
of lower level football I just don't see
how you're going to stop this big excess
money in a way creating a tier of
football teams within the Premier League
that just beat everyone else because
they can afford to I just I don't
nothing you've said to me today explains
to me how you think for the good of the
league
you can stop that happening well I'm
sure if um you know your your you asked
me about Manchester City I'm sure
Manchester City if their CEO is sitting
here today or their Finance director he
would tell you every Monday morning he's
looking at a set of financials where
they're looking at their position in
financial fair play Financial fair play
rules which have been in in 10 years for
10 years all change have changed the way
the clubs run better I assure you I've
run three clubs every Monday morning I
get my weekly Finance report and there
is a line compliance with financial fair
play which in plain English that means
how much money you are allowed to lose
it is controlled what I'm suggesting to
you is those rules may need to get
stronger they need may need to be
policed even more effectively but we
have a system of financial regulation
and it is designed to make sure people
do not overspend that's where we are in
football today one more thing then you
think that the Premier League's at an
inflection point now that either if you
get it right now you you guarantee the
sustainability over the next decade and
if you don't we're going to have a
league in which doesn't reflect what it
used to be I absolutely agree we're at
an inflection point if we don't take the
right action on those regulations and
enforce them properly the league could
look very different in 20 years time
that is our Beauty and responsibility as
football administrators and Christian
thank you so much talk to you it's
absolutely fascinating and very good
luck with your Endeavor to get into
European football for Aston Villa thank
you this season that's very exciting
thanks so much cheers thank you thanks
thank you
Christian parsley there what a
fascinating discussion I hope you
enjoyed it I learned a lot from it well
that's all for this week's show if you
scan the QR code on your screen right
now you can listen to the Beth Rigby
interviews podcast each week I take a
look at the highlights of my interviews
and there are some extra bits and pieces
in there too that'll be on the Sky News
app or wherever you get your podcast
that's all for this week's show in this
fabulous setting thank you to Christian
parslow for his time and thank you for
watching
[Music]